[Musik]
hallöchen eliten heute gibt einen
chocolate cheesecake google wird wie ich
jetzt drauf komme vor genau einem jahr
sind wir hier eingezogen und zu dieser
umzugsphase wo ich noch diese ganze
küche je nicht hatte und wir einfach nur
schränke aufgebaut haben haben wir uns
den immer von der bäckerei gegenüber
geholt und jetzt habe ich mir gedacht
das rezept muss ich unbedingt mal zeigen
aber ich finde generell das cheesecake
und schokoladenkuchen kombinationen top
ist genau wie du sagst und jetzt zeige
ich euch zu aller erst mal die
zubereitung zu den schoko tag dann
machen wir die cheesecake masse und dann
wird alles miteinander vereint und hier
habe ich jetzt schon butter in meiner
küche maschine
ich mache das jetzt mit der
küchenmaschine weil die butter die
mussten zimmer waren sein
da gebe ich jetzt auch noch zucker und
vanille extrakt hinzu und die muss fünf
minuten lang richtig schön cremig also
richtig schön hell cremig geschlagen
stimmt auch gleich den timer und wenn
ihr ein handrührgerät habe dann braucht
es eine verachten da brauchte immer so
ein bisschen länger
[Musik]
nach den fünf minuten geben wir zur
mutter die eier die gebe ich jetzt nach
und nach dazu und da ist es besser wenn
die auf zimmertemperatur sind genauso
wie die milch die gleiche in zukunft die
sollte auch auf zimmertemperatur sein
und die milch gebe ich im nachhinein
dann abwechselnd in den trockenen
zutaten mit zur masse und die trockenen
zutaten könnte der einfachheit halber
auch vorher miteinander verrühren
[Musik]
und das ist der fertige schokolade
ich schreibe euch wie immer alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben mail bei kakao etc
alles unten individuell beschreibung
daher unbedingt einmal unter dem titel
aufklappen und er trägt auch schon
weiter mit dem greenpeace mit dieser
kiesfüllung und dafür habe ich hier
natürlich doktor am frischkäse der
schmeckt mir am allerbesten
ich verzichte jetzt auf quark weil ich
hier dieses reichhaltige diesen
reichhaltigen cremigen geschmack so mag
und da gebe ich jetzt etwas speisestärke
dazu dann habe ich hier noch ein eigelb
und eiweiß könnt ihr dann einfach zu
rührei weiterverarbeiten
sodann habe ich hier noch etwas sahne
natürlich zucker und auch noch mal
wahrnehmen extrakt für den geschmack und
das verwöhnen wird ganz einfach alles
zusammen
so nachdem jetzt alles vorbereitet ist
müssen wir nur noch unseren gugelhupf
befüllen und alles miteinander vereint
und ich gebe euch einen tipp gibt vorher
back trends bei großzügig in den
guglhupf und nimmt dann eine mischung
aus mehl und bacau dann habt ihr wenn
ihr das ganze nachher stürzt auch kein
unschönen mehr rand an der oberfläche
also alle die schon mal gelobt gemacht
haben und das ganze war ein schoko
google hub und ihr habt ihr mit mehr
ausgeschöpft die verstehen nicht dass
meine ich schreibe euch aber sowieso wie
immer alle tipps auch wieder unten in
der infobox und jetzt gebe ich hier die
hälfte des schoko teigs einmal in den
guglhupf anteil den schön versuche auch
so ein rand hochzuziehen und dann kommt
dass die greenpeace masse da rein
[Musik]
selbst schließt natürlich mit dem
schokoladen teig wieder ab und versuchte
sein oben noch mal so ein bisschen glatt
zu streichen und jetzt wandert unser
chocolate cheesecake guglhupf in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 175 grad ober
und unterhitze für circa 60 minuten ist
könnte fünfter und länger oder kürzer
dauern macht auf jeden fall die probe
mit dem schaschlikspieß wenn kein
flüssiger oder feuchter teig dran hängen
bleibt dann ist ein gugelhupf gar und
wir sehen uns höchstwahrscheinlich
morgen entweder weil es ihm vollständig
auskühlen lassen und anschließend
stürzte also würde ich mal sagen bis
morgen der liebe hat mich darauf
hingewiesen dass ich heute wieder sehr
schnell spreche ich welche entscheidest
du isst aber ich mag es schnell zu
quasseln ich glaube ihr habt euch auch
schon dran gewöhnen
da sag ich rede schnell aber klar
deutlich dass das müssten wir lassen
jetzt kommt er ganz langsam in dem
backofen user bis morgen sind die letzte
video sequenz ist irgendwie verloren
gegangen trotzdem möchte ich mich jetzt
ganz persönlich verabschieden ihr müsst
den job jetzt schießt die kugel
unbedingt nachmachen der schnitt so
saftig jeder der davon probieren durfte
hat gesagt geil möchte ich aber wohl
wieder essen also unbedingt nachmachen
und abonniert main kanal komplett
kostenlos dann verpasst ja auch nichts
mehr
und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten
rezept video oder eurem nächsten blog
denn wir würden auch wieder fleißig und
ja ich sag mal bis zum nächsten video
cherokee
[Musik]